[Music]
just one day after ei was forced to
confirm battlefield hardline following a
leak ahead of its III presentation what
appears to be an internal video for the
game has found its way online I'm step
forward with a GS news update the
trailer certainly looks the real deal
and at seven minutes long it's no teaser
either titled Project Omaha and
watermark is confidential to EA the
video reportedly details the story game
modes multiplayer engine actors and
basically everything ea could possibly
hope to hold back for its official III
reveal according to the trailer
multiplayer will focus on tactical
gameplay including hostage rescues bank
heists and getaway chases a mode listed
as Blood Money details aid cops V
criminals battle over a cash haul to be
secured and brought back to the team's
starting area the single-player follows
a Miami detectives called Nick Mendoza
straddling the good guy a bad guy line
he'll be joined by an assorted gang of
dirty cops and shady criminals in a
level structure based on popular crime
television shows with the game's vocal
talents scooped up from shows such as
justified the Americans and house of
cards a redesigned AI system and larger
levels than previous games are
highlighted including the ability to
replay levels and scenarios in different
ways the bombastic map changing event
they call evolution returns featuring
all the destructible world gameplay of
its predecessors the game will feature
an assortment of real and fictional
weapons and accessories including a
scanner detailing a target's criminal
records in multiplayer zip lines and
grappling hooks add a layer of
verticality to game while there appears
to be a heap of new land sea and air
based vehicles to ride around on the
game is due to be officially detailed on
June 9th at 12 p.m. Pacific during phase
III presentations but do let us know
what you make of the game info so far is
this the revolution of the series that
you've been hoping for and don't forget
to tune in to that presentation live
from e3
right here at GameSpot calm
you
[Music]